同學們,大家晚安
今天蠻多同學先問問題的
那我們就先來把問題看過一次
看得到我嗎?應該OK啦
那我們就先從剛剛問問題的幾個同學開始
最前面有個同學問6139這支股票
在這裡
你問我說日K是空方標準圖嗎?
日K是空方標準圖嗎?
我跟你說,日K還不是
日線的話它還需要再一個上
這樣才會變成空方標準圖
不過在小刻度裡面,60分K
或許就已經開始有,60分K也還沒有
還差一些些,所以忍耐一下,還沒有完全
剛剛有另外一個同學問6180
這個就比較有小10k的
日k一樣,日k還不是空方標準圖
不要看到這樣就空喔
這個只有在小10k這裡
小10k你塗鴉一下
上、下、上、下、上
所以如果在小10k裡面
你剛好可以看得出這件事情
這個慣性才真的開始有改變
好不好?那日K有沒有?還沒有
所以你就心裡要知道這個是一個
有的確日K有可能有壓力
但是它還沒有真的完全爛掉
就只有在更小刻度裡面的事情
好不好?那有個同學問這個中國的股票
601968這個
我剛好叫出來了
來
在這支股票你說
这种剧烈的震荡也能够作为标准图吗
当然可以啊
只要有价格的
成交量不要太低
只要有价格在波动的
就能够判断是不是标准图
但是我并不是说这个就是标准图
而是它的日线来看
这边一坨日线塞在这个地方
好丑
所以我进到短格局
短格局你说
5.25这个位置是关键边缘吗
5.25大概在这个位置
这个位置你是看这边的吧
对吧
如果这个价格在这边要有效它应该就要停在这边但是事实上5.25对最近这边来讲它一点意义都没有
真正有意义的是这个或这个
这个才是市场亲眼
它定义给我看的东西
5.25是在这边
我猜的
但是在这边5.25已经被拿掉了
跟这个5.25一点关系都没有了
都沒有了
好不好
然後再來還有同學問
我剛好看到周縣是不是
這裡
周K是關鍵邊緣嗎?
想要等漲上去回來這附近吃
是可以啦
只不過你希望有心理準備
這個漲上去回來這邊
如果有這件事情發生
可能要一到兩個月
因為你看的是周K
四个礼拜才一周
所以四根,几根上去又几根回来
可能一到两个月没错
那如果有,这边会很棒
只是我想要问的是问
既然你都在看周K的偷摸
前一根周K的底下这里,60块附近这里
在这边有整理了几天
这些边界,如果你是要偷摸周K的店
其实这边的边界已经不错
甚至包含这个
上下這附近
也就是說今天來到這附近
你在這邊吃
我會覺得這是一個很合理的做法
因為它已經是在邊界區域了
但如果你都已經看到周K了
其實你不用太拘泥在
我一定要吃在精準的那個價格
你的刻度可以稍微寬一點點
你都已經在做周了
對吧
然後還有2609
有同學說日K是聰明的摸嗎?
日K如果你摸在48塊出頭這附近
但如果你摸在49塊就是靠上半部的日K
這邊是不好的,不行的
這樣好不好?
還有什麼呢?
這支有同學問我說這個華興科是不是關鍵邊緣
這邊界還不錯喔
這個邊界還不錯,其實看起來就是
有人在吃
有一些下影線,有人在吃的樣子
那這種東西又是長顆度滿足區大顆度邊界這個的算好防守我會講好防守就代表我不確定它會不會漲但是它整體判斷下來
我可以用低風險去換
換換看
換比較大的利潤
看換不換得到
這個我覺得還OK
這樣好不好
然後呢
有同學說我NQ下午
沒有喔
NQ下午那點我錯過了
這裡這裡
這個點我錯過了
如果我有在盤前我一定吃
但是这个时候
来,这个时候我错过了
这是下午3点多,快4点这附近
对,没有没有
我下午出去走一段
走走,那走走的时候就错过这一段了
然后等我回来了
我会在想睡觉
大概就是这样
好吧
我今天穿的衣服还有特效感,真的吗?
不会是3D特效吧?
來來來,我要看一下
我看一下
這個衣服
真的嗎?衣服很有特效,我看一下旁邊
各位,這樣子
如果你會因為這樣而演花聊飯跟我說一下
我去換個衣服
好嗎?
有人要看比特幣啊?好,比特幣,來
我沒有在做,但是都一樣
比特幣4小时线是不是头尖底
我没有在看4小时,不过没关系
看一下,不行
来,一个破底翻要长这样子
我问你,这个涂鸦出来
我涂鸦出来,来看一下
我的涂鸦
哪来的破底翻,你告诉我
这张图跟这个图
跟...等一下
這樣子
這兩個圖根本就不一樣啊
不行不行
NO! NO NO NO
好不好
縮小才有放大就正常
有同學說什麼
NQ月底月初上午真的一點都不動
對啊你就等下午再玩就好
所以上午你根本可以直接休息的
你知道嗎?
對吧?
衣服橫紋會閃
好啦,各位
等我一下,我立刻就換個衣服這是...絕對不會在這邊換,你放心等等我一下我就換個衣服為了顧及大家的眼睛
咱们看了
哈囉,我回來了
來啦來啦,回來了
這件呢
直播換裝
這件呢,這件應該好多了吧
好嗎
不太能想像我穿西裝
自從我離開在券商服務以後
我就很懶得穿西裝
也懶得穿皮鞋
就变成是穿球鞋、运动服这种休闲的
所以我有解除成就了
耶
好吧
但是我跟大家习惯看的那种换衣服不一样
什么换个烧的,拜托不要
来
昨天,前两天我去逛那个年货大街
在路上被一位网友认出来
你是老鱼吗
你知道他第一句话跟我说什么吗?
他第一句话跟我说,你怎么那么黑
我有在打棒球啊,所以基本上每个礼拜在晒,一定是黑的啊
他说直播看起来是白的,所以我现场看好黑啊
好不好,来,所以比特币刚刚这个
如果你说的是说这里,Paul,Defano
如果是这样,我给过,但是这不是4小时K
而且边界其实我个人认为
你可以稍微等它一下
等它再戳下来一点点
会比较平衡
比较下来一点这样
如果你看的是这边这个破底翻
甚至如果可以到
碰到這個,如果這邊有這個,這個會好很多
OK
好,那
再來,剛剛我同學問台子期
他說他空在,我剛剛上面好像有瞄到
他空在這裡,18009這裡
6點整,大概在這附近
你空在這裡,你說好不好
這樣講好了
如果你是在做標準圖的
這邊其實沒有標準圖的交易
我要怎麼塗鴉的出標準圖?沒有耶
這邊塗鴉起來就是長這樣子
它沒有任何標準圖可言
那你說位置對不對?位置對了
有沒有一些上癮線?有
那你空在邊界頂多只能說就是聰明摸
你在滿足區的角度去做這件事
那理論上你現在應該早就停損了
那就算它停損掉
或是你打不賠
這樣就好
好不好
再來接受看一下同學問的
創意
你說小10K
哎喲
尖尖的隔壁
這個聰明耶
這個尖尖的隔壁好吃
吃的不錯
拍拍手
以60K來講
你這個給過
而且是一個很聰明的讀法
這種的
應該講聰明摸
比起刚刚台子棋的那位同学来的更聪明
为什么会这样讲
因为台子棋的那个
他并没有这种很显而易见
一个超明确
出去又说进来的
他没有
他是连续好几根的那个地方
在那边混啊混啊混
有没有
这种看起来
好像很尖很尖
戳出去又回来的这个
这个是我很爱的东西
这样好吗
那你说我在玩游戏吗
有啊
之前一開始暗黑市出來的時候有在玩
不過暗黑市真的現在就
偶爾就懶懶的玩一下這樣而已
好不好
看再來
272337日線是好的出手位置嗎
有同學說剛剛那個對不對
喔來來來
說這個是不是這樣子對不對
有這一根就解除了啊
诶,等一下各位,你不需要捐款
不要花钱我下次要把这个功能给关掉不用花钱才能让我看到,好吗?不要这样子大家就随意让我眼睛看得到就看得到
OK
我刚刚讲什么
对啦
先切一个
然后你要问我什么呢?2337的日线
哎呦,日線也不錯
日線還OK哦
因為他們都有出現共同的變化就是
不該跌破的邊界,跌破又收回來的這個動作
哎呦,同學們,讚!
你們有把我們交的東西吸收進去
而且又是在這個大邊界
所以這個還不錯哦
你說你要喊我老徐對不對
來,6113,就看同學這個
1月26號9點09分3分鐘K
等一下喔
第一個
股票我從來不推薦看這種幾分K的
我連5分K都不看
股票最低60分K
你不要學人家做什麼短線那個
什麼五本當沖啊
哇!股票獻股當沖
死的人一大票
活着的是少数非常少
可能10万个人才一个
或是20万个人才一个活下来
其他死掉的都不会讲话
所以你完全都不知道这些死掉的多少人
不要做献骨当冲
拜托不需要
你不用做那么累
好吗
拜托拜托拜托拜托
好不好
所以三分钟我用五分可以看
1月26
1月26很前面
这里
你说这里吗
3分K
9.09
9点
这里
有啊
你看这里的破底翻吗
有啊这里有标准图
3分K可能有
我这边没有办法去切那个3分钟
我顶多就这样子看
好不好
所以OK啊
这个没什么问题
但是你不要只看这样子
你要看一下大颗度啦我是很强烈的建议你不要看那么小你做那么小你自己看你的这支股票从16噴到42然后我们小闭只小眼睛的在那里看一分钟看三分钟
然后看着旁边的人摆着丢个两个礼拜什么事都不用做
赚的比你多很多你在那玩什么啦
不要不准
毕业文超多而且很多死掉的人
那是不會上台講話的
這叫生存者偏差
ok
我們今天來聊一下今天的主題
等一下我們可以用
眼前的小納的行情
或是同學要我看的行情
我們來這樣子
ok
同學說什麼以為會漲,結果會跌
等一下
以為會漲,結果跌
這關於什麼事
做標準圖不代表
一定会涨一定会跌啊
有标准图啊对啊
你就是图来的打图完的打
来我问你打投手来
如果投手投过来的球
我以为这一球要安打
他就一定要安打吗
被人家美技皆杀
或是你自己打不好挥棒落空
就挥棒落空啊
对吧
结果完全不关你的事
你在乎的是
你有没有用标准动作在做你的出手
然后做你的计划出场
真的有来
哦耶
老天爷给面子
那是老天爷帮你的忙
那是你运气好
如果没有来
你本来就不会来啊
他不来
不来就不来啊
跟我屁事
你要抱着这种心态在做交易
好吧
你说祥品都全来打
对不起
那个是人
那不是人
那是另外一个世界
那是神
好吧
我不能把它拿来玩
如果你有玩棒球游戏
你把大股祥品的资料丢进游戏里面
那就不用玩了
他一个人就可以了
好不好
好来
我们来先来聊今天的这个主题
待会也会有时间来跟大家聊天
好不好
第一个
我们过去这几周
我们断断续续的
从11月一路聊过来
聊了我们为什么用裸街看盘
聊了两条线翻亚当标准图
以及边界乱打等等
真的,我們今天要把所有的這些技巧
把它拼起來
看我們在實際上看盤的時候到底會用到哪些東西好不好来先公告一下下个礼拜四是过年了已经是小年业
所以我已经出去玩了
所以我不在家
好不好
所以交易业暂停一次
那在下个礼拜
我看情形
到时候会公告给大家
那如果你是有加那个频道会员的
那个不受影响
我会去挑几支
我在過去在小群組裡面直播
而且是當下的行情
有做出一些很棒的一些教學跟講解的東西
我會播給大家
我會挑出來
好不好
挑一些大家說
哇這個要加精華很棒
通常都是那支影片我丟了很多次筆
有沒有
老師在說你有沒有在聽
那待會我們看看會不會有機會讓我丟筆
OK
然後剛剛最上面有個同學
有同學連續留言了好幾次
我說什麼他好像都賺不到錢還是什麼
我看一下哪裡
這裡
你說十幾天贏一單
基本持平
喔你輸十幾天贏一單就持平
不錯啊
對吧
你這樣子問問題我要怎麼回答你
這是
這我能怎麼回答你啊
對吧這問題本身
我也不知道要從哪裡開始啊
好不好
來
我們先直接就跳進來講主題講重點
那在我的交易裡面有三問
三個問我先快速給大家看
叫做位置對不對
慣性對不對
還有圖對不對
位置慣性圖
有順序的喔
你要照順序的問
你不能倒著看過來喔
如果順序不對你會死得很慘
他必須要有對的順序
所以第一個叫做位置對不對
兩條線畫出來
我們就用當下的圖
來,兩條線畫出來
所以以剛剛的小鈉
剛剛的這是小鈉的15分K
就算在這邊長上去以前
你應該都可以在
來,在最末端
你應該這裡
長上去以前你應該都畫得出兩條線
你不用畫得很精準
我們講過那個線是一個區域
是一個像海綿一樣的區域
它不會是精準的一個價格
但是就是這一區
反正就這一區
你心中就要有個底
所以有個底了
好來
這個刻度
就是長這樣子,這是15分K
如果我切成60分K的
60分K的
目前小的也在這裡
比較大一點的大概是這樣子
那你就知道說
在這個地方,我放大給大家看
嗯...
好,這樣子
來,在這裡有小刻度的兩條線
然後呢,稍微大一點點
有這邊,藍色的兩條線
來,我問各位喔
什麼地方
有比较多的线重叠
大小刻度都压在差不多的边界
是不是上半部这边
我故意没有画很精准
因为不需要很精准
很多人都把精准的东西放在行情上
行情怎么可能精准
对吧
它是活的
全世界这么多人在做交易
它一定是模糊比对
OK
所以第一个
位置对不对
那既然
我们在做交易
来
刚好眼前的五分K
这边借我用
我先说
我并不是每一次
都只做这么短线
但是因为今天
我们就只有短短的教学时间
我就希望在我们的这个时间里面
我能够有东西给大家
所以我们就先从这两条线开始
所以上面的线下面的线
好底下的线到了
好线到了来
限到了,对不对
惯性,对不对
我说涂鸦,治百病
那涂鸦,治百病怎么治
来
各位,涂鸦很多种
你在涂鸦的时候
你需要
涂鸦的时候
你需要照着
K棒的最末端,这个上引线
下引线,这个多少图
我先示范一个不好的涂鸦
你不能这样子
不能这样子
不能这样子涂鸦哦
你这样子涂鸦
这些东西都被你忽略掉
这种涂鸦的方式
我只要应用在辨认标准图的部分
这样好不好
所以前面这边我先不涂鸦
我涂鸦这里就好了
来注意看
注意看这边
跌多
涨少
没有真的跌多
涨多
跌少
这里
涨多,跌少,涨不多哎呀,请问你这边看到了是不是价格从本来的本来涨的幅度只有这样子
现在跌的幅度是不是多于涨的幅度
对吧
所以眼前来到这个边界的惯性
对或不对
惯性就不对了哦
如果是以做多来讲
这惯性不对哦
这样可以吗
所以惯性不对
通常会伴随着很凶很凶的K棒
来我们来定义一下
什么叫很凶的K棒
好不好
很凶的K棒就是
一根K棒
通常是实体K棒很大根
或是一个很长的上引线或下引线
这个我都可以把它定义为很凶
不要被K棒的长相给蒙蔽了
你要想的是想
这个K棒怎么会长这样子
例如说一根这样子的K棒
这样子
其实后面这边再继续破下去
是天经地义的事情
在我们看来一点意外都没有
一根K棒的开盘架在这边
中间经历过上上下下
然后它就咻咻咻咻
一直往下涨
就像眼前这一根一样
开盘架在这边
这根K棒的最后一个时间在这边
所以就会变成一个时薪的
下跌的K棒
就跟这根一样
这就是很凶的K棒
好吗
那这种K棒出现
后面破底的几率
非常非常
非常非常非常高
高到我不知道要用几个非常
好吗
你说老鱼这边没有啊
我说的是几率
OK
但是就算这个地方
我没有吃也无所谓啊
因为那不是我要看的东西
好不好
再来
所以涂鸦本身
我们做一个多头的
例如说这边
这边这个地方
注意看哦
光涂鸦就自白病
涂鸦涂鸦
涂鸦到眼前这边
请问你惯性往哪走
一秒钟就要看得出来
你不用任何的脑袋去思考
你的眼睛会告诉你
對吧?那反觀後面這邊
來,塗鴉、塗鴉這邊
這裡,欸?你光塗鴉本身有沒有可能就涂鸦了出比较像是标准涂的东西这样目前可以理解我讲的吗?光涂鸦就在救你
甚至很多人喜欢在这种地方做空,在这种地方就直接做空
来,我们来咯,这边,我这边涂快一点,这边,请问你,真的有惯性改变吗?
有往下的惯性了吗?有变跌多长少吗?没有
没有
但是一旦来到这个地方
你是不是看得出来
你的涂鸦本身就够了
有同学说
我头发白多了
我没事吧
我其实本来就摆头发
前一段时间我就买那个染黑的洗发精
就是那个张志豪代言的那个
然后那段时间的头发用掉了以后
就摆头发又长出来
我们家有白头发的基因
所以没有办法
所以大概再几年你就看到我全部都白了
应该是这样子吧
好不好
来
所以
第一问是对的位置
第二问是我要对的惯性
所以按照刚刚这样来讲
在这个地方
我需要它在上边界
下边界
我需要它在这里干嘛
我需要它在这边让我能够涂鸦涂鸦涂鸦
如果我可以在这个地方涂鸦出这个东西来
所以它就会是就会是在对的位置出现对的惯性
而且也有我要的图
这样想法OK
好不好
但是它眼前有没有出现
没有
各位眼前光这一段哦
我現在講的這一段,這都是對我來講真實行情
各位可能會比我慢個大概10秒20秒吧
所以我沒有任何猶豫的空間
這不是我在吃標準圖的圖
所以這張圖
如果要變成標準圖,會需要跌破
然後這邊又兜兜兜兜長上來
又兜兜兜兜長回來
也就是說它需要
例如我組合給大家看
它需要這邊這樣子
然後呢
再一個上下
這樣子如果到這個地方來我就可以從这边涂鸦的出标准图有看得到,看得到我现在画的吗?
如果有右边这个位置来了,有机会躲后面,我就吃了
这样,那如果这边出现像这样子的图,这里出现像这样子的图
在隔壁可不可以聰明的摸一下
可以
那就知道說眼前這邊是在更小刻度內
可能是在1分K裡面的標準圖
那你自己去看
你最做的就是在1分K的事
所以這個是比較
比較算是比較早期的進場點
還沒有到完全標準
但是它其實已經有慣性的改變
你要在這邊測試我覺得也OK了
這想法OK嗎
所以眼前的这些其实都有包含我们讲的那个尖尖的喔
这样好不好
再来
所以第一问位置
第二问惯性
第三图
对不对
是我在等的图吗
例如说
假设你是一个喜欢做空的人
做空的人
你是一个喜欢做空的人
那眼前这个地方怎么样都不会有
怎么样都不会有你要空单的图
对不对
所以如果你是喜欢做空的人
你根本是直接把眼前的行情直接放掉
你就不要理他
除非他变成什么
他多多多多跌进来
然后又涨回来了
又来到这个地方
然后你看到
原来更大的刻度有这种
本来的压力变支撑
如果在这边又变互换
你在这个时候醒过来
笔太粗了
换一下
你在這個時候醒過來
這樣就夠了
不需要
等於現在都完全跟你無關
你既然是要做空
那現在是人家做多準備在發威的時候
你就等啊
等他發威結束看長什麼樣
如果他來到這邊
如果他從這邊來來來來
來到這個地方上不去
你再來空
或許還比較有話說
對不對
ok
有同學說想知道台幣跟比特幣
線都做頭肩底
哪個會勝利?你在找聖杯耶
哪個會勝利?
我拿銅板,我口袋裡面有銅板
我找一個銅板,我丟銅板幫你來找
幫你來看一下
欸,銅板,銅板
好了,來,我用銅板來幫你解決
人頭是台幣,然後
字的那邊就是另外一個,比特幣
人頭,台幣會贏
人頭,好了
老魚,已經用銅板幫你解決你的問題
好不好
来
我还要再延伸
还不是单纯只有这样子
我们现在都在讲进场
记不记得我们有教大家翻亚当这个东西
对吧
翻亚当
所以两条线标准图翻亚当
刚刚目前为止都还没用到翻亚当啊
对吧
来
我们可以计划
如果我在这边吃到
如果
假设这边有我刚刚说
收尖尖的隔壁的这个单子
假设
然后我吃到了以后还没有往上翻哦
我可不可以虚拟的
假装
我在我的脑袋里面假想一下
如果市场是这样走上去
可能可以把这一段
给走出去
哦那我可能可以计划一下
诶那我可能可以在这边出场
哦那我承受
这样子的风险
做這樣子的
賺這樣子的地數
嗯合理合理
好這個我可以來做
這個想法你在當初
這邊的時候
是不是
如果你吃在這裡
你是不是就可以先計畫好
如果我吃在這
東東翻上去
我可能可以
這邊如果我可以放在這邊
把這個嘎出去
我可能可以出在320
我剛剛早上好像
前面我看到有同學
就是這樣子出
那你就出在320
所以如果你有做这一段,那后面就是你的
那你说后面他是喷到350,怎么办
后面那是后面的事啊
你当初的计划,如果就只有计划到这边
你就照着你原来的计划出场
这样就好了
还有喔,亚当理论我还会运用另外一个东西
来,眼前正好是一个好案例
这边到这边,约略的满足区,到了
就刚刚到了
這張圖5分K這裡K棒下來跌破邊界下來還沒有它其實沒有完全一样所以如果你亚当翻得够多你心中就知道这一段
的距离会约略等于翻下来
这一段的距离
包含我们再看这里
这里也是啊你看出现这一根
它是不是涨破的前面
真的假的会延续吗
对吧
我不会在这种地方秩序的做多
应该这样讲
我不会是空手
然后在这里才空手进去
我会是在底下吃到单子
一路凹到这边
看到这一单
好
拼给你拼
拼把这个拼上去
这一段
拼上去
好
在这边出场
这样
这是我会做的事情
我图根本就一个样
好像
有没有
所以我不会去
去用翻亚当拿来做进场
这个其实我们过去在讲亚当的时候
其实都讲过了
我会拿来做出场
所以回头先讲一下
进场的逻辑很简单
就只是在值得出手的边界
然后等我要的图
讲完哦
等待那个惯性弯回来的图
所以你说我是不是接刀
不是
我已经不是接刀了
因为我的涂鸦都能够让我
我的涂鸦都能够让我在关键边缘
涂鸦变成这样子
怎么可能会是接刀呢
接刀是我的涂鸦都还是长这样子
这才叫做接刀
一旦它能够让我涂鸦变成这样子弯过来
那就不一样了
这样好不好
有同学说Linbei
超棒
超爱听
我考试问大家
眼前的涂鸦
惯性变成涨多跌少了吗
一秒钟要告诉我
眼前惯性有变成涨多跌少吗
没有对不对
那如果没有
你在这边拼命的接干嘛
可能只有在1分K里面
1分K里面正要涨多
有1分K有
我看得出来
其实我刚刚看那个5分K
我大概就知道它要停住
但是
1分K正好出现
这就是我们讲的
来没有任何一个K棒过高
没有任何一个K棒过高
没有任何K棒过高一直到这边哎哟过去了对吧那这个只是第一步你先等他這邊再這樣子再回來這個圖會好很多,不要太急
哇,各位
這樣子不算站上去喔
這樣子不算站上喔,不行喔
因為他曾經上去又被人家拿鐵錘扣扣扣的敲下來
不行
所以真的上去是你要收盘架收在
这一根的收盘架
它必须要收在这边
要维持着大K棒的样子
这样我才能够说
哦,它的惯性真的改变
对吧
我现在切1分K
不代表我推荐大家做1K
我再度重申
我只是因为
我们的教学时间就只有这么短
我只好在1K里面跟大家做
我平常做的刻度
其实我喜欢做很大的刻度
因为大刻度的好处是
我可以同时间去睡午觉
然后我同时间有我的部位
我可以出去玩一两天
我的部位都还在
一两个月我的部位还在
我喜欢做这种大刻度
谁说
谁说trader一定要
每分每秒这样定在盘前
然后做一大堆商品
谁说的
那个真的有啦
在电视上很多很厉害的电视上
真实世界里面做越多赔越多
我们都是神
我们不是神
拜托
请你很诚心的相信自己很烂
然后把你观察的东西剪得越少越好
把心事抽离开
好吗
你说我是不是把红绿色兑换
对啊
因为我最近在截图
截一些图给之后书要用的东西
然后因为台湾大家习惯是这样子
我其实是觉得好像都OK
我记得这好像是我某一次
同学在问的时候
我把它改过来
然后我就忘记改回去
其实都没有差
好不好
尖尖的隔壁吃
这个并不是随时都拿出来用
它只有在三问都对的时候
你才会拿尖尖的出来看
但是很多人都忘记
要先去判断位置
惯性图
拿到任何一张图
看到任何一个尖尖的就冲进去
然后就兴高采烈的进去然后头破血轮的出来不要这样子我们只有在三问都对的时候才有尖尖的例如说老鱼老鱼尖尖的
隔壁也吃
请问一下
眼前的这里拿来的标准图
我就问你嘛
但很多人看到一个尖尖的
又是一个满足区尖尖的
就吃了
拜托不要
这个地方的这边有这个东西
这些借我用,例如说这个
如果这个在这里
我比较明确的借好了
如果这一坨东西是在这里
大概这样子
这样
这里有东西
你在这里这样子吃,这个是1K喔
1K这样代表这个前一次是5分K或15分K在这里
然后这样子吃
这是我最勉强给过的最早的出手点
你在1K我這樣勉強給過
但是他沒有啊
很多人都是喜歡這樣懸空的
就開始猜猜猜猜猜猜
然後懸空的去猜空單空單空單
有啦你前面猜的這些
你都先死一大票
然後等市場來塗鴉
等市場轉彎了
你看得出來啊
但是你已經沒錢了
你前面都賠掉了
何苦勒
好不好
来喔
眼前来
我们刚好看到大颗度的边界
来来来
上圆
sorry
这是上圆
刚刚本来小颗度的涂鸦在这边
有没有
然后我还有涂一个比较大一点点的
那时候我说大概抓这边
所以眼前就好玩啦
中间这条线我暂时就先不理它
因为它价格从这边
跑到这边来了
对吧
记不记得刚刚在最一开始直播的时候
然后那时候正好行情还在上面
记得我们说什么吗
我们说上面这边的线
来考试
刚刚前面有听的同学
上面这边除了有短格局的
两条线的上缘
是不是还有一个大刻度的上缘
对吧
来这样看
对不对
所以你心中就要知道说
上面这边
本来就不容易做
你看位置对不对
位置重不重要
所以
你在做
假设你在这个地方
你想要跟着追多
例如说这个地方
哇
你要跟着追上去
你往左边一看
前面人家都在这边
出现一大堆上影线
一大堆上影线
这样
然后呢
什么东西
我说一大堆上影线
那你就真的觉得
你的这个钢盔撞得过去吗
不要吧
要撞给别人撞
撞上去了回來變底部
我再來吃都好
我不喜歡做撞牆
所以你只要位置對了
基本上你贏了八成你知道嗎
我給大家看一個單子
這是我
這是我昨天
應該講前一天
再前一天
看到60分K在上面
我用買保險的角度
我不是真的很喜歡做空
但是我用買保險的角度
去幫我美股的部位做一些避險
然後我空在這邊
然後早上的時候我隨意把這個成本拉在這個地方
這樣子
那那個位置
來
60分可以超明顯啊
這邊就
上不去上不去
這邊就一大堆上不去啊
然後又是底下的
滿足區
又是上不去
對吧
所以位置對了
就贏一大半
前一段时间做多也是一样啊
前一段时间做多
一样啊
我现在是小10k哦
小10k如果是在前一段时间
在这边你会怎么画出两条线
上元下元一秒钟
蹦蹦就定义出来了对吧
所以你做在容易涨上去的边界
然后你不要再靠近
容易下跌的边界去做多嘛
所以你看市场就长这样
对不对
你说怎么没有等个尖尖的
你说这个地方吗
我不是单纯这样子吃
我记得我当时有看到
我的成本好像在17还是20这附近
我吃在这附近吧
好像是吧
我没有很精确的记得
大概在这附近这样
大概在1720这里这样
好像是18吧
空单避险的概念
就买保险啊
就股票很贵了买保险以防它跌下来讲完了做法一模一樣,就只是漲不上去的地方你買保險你要捨得付保險費
所以我當時所承受的停損就是我要付的保險費
如果沒有
沒有理賠,保費就被吃掉
對不對?不然就是這樣子
OK
來
这个
各位我们今天讲的东西我们开始发生
哦!眼前有个好观料给大家
压力支撑不是一个精准的点
现在哦,我不会把边界画在这里
我会把边界画在这里
而这里,这里跟这个
这几件事情在眼前的我看起来是同一件事
所以你要用哪一个K棒
哪一个格局的K棒去捕捉它
随便你,那是你的计划
我觉得没有好坏
对5K来讲,来请问各位
现在的价格是由上而下
撞这条线,还是由下而上撞这条线
1 2 3
由下而上
所以我不会在这边做任何做多的想法
不会,因为它很明显是由下而上
在测试这个边界,这我不喜欢
而且你怎么涂鸦也涂鸦不出我们讲的标准图
都没有,所以也不会是我做的
所以你在做交易的時候
其實你可以很清楚的去
看到眼前的市場到底是由
由哪邊測試哪邊
你知道我現在講的喔
全部都是正規交易裡面很重要在觀察市場的東西
這樣好不好
有同學說好想追多,你就追啊
不要理我啊,說不定你是對的,你看上去的
你就追啊,不要理我啊
那如果是追多的同學
對你來講,防守
等一下喔,嗆到
對你來講,防守要怎麼守
超難守耶,明明剛剛這邊有下不去的點
如果你要多,你剛剛這邊不吃
在這邊才追多,你還是要防守到這邊
好遠喔
對吧
這就是我不喜歡用追的概念
所以凡是我的文字裡面
我需要用到追
光追這個字就不對了就跟你交女朋友一樣啊你喜歡男女生其實是互相吸引的你不用去追如果是需要你很用力去追的
代表那也不是你的啦
是你的你根本不太需要追
自然而然兩個就走在一起了
大概就是這樣
好不好
有同學說這樣要看哪一個
挑一個啊
如果你要做15K
15K的這裡也沒有好點耶
15K的唯一好點是隔壁這根再回來一點點的這裡
15K沒有好點,沒有
這個地方的15K是不能吃的15K
所以你選一個啊
你到底是要5K
然後遵守5K看到的東西
還是你要用15K遵守15K看到的東西
OK啊
最忌諱,我要講忌諱
就是你在做5K
看到隔壁同學用15K,哎呀他用的好像不錯
不然我也用15看看
結果你用了15k他比較慢
然後看到另外一個同學用1分k
賺得要死要活的
哇!好像1k也不錯耶
同學同學請問你1k怎麼做的
我就這樣子做這樣子做
我也來試試看
又跑到1k
不如我1k5k15k
我三個同一時間都看好了
我就看1k有機會
我就用他的方式
15k有機會我就用他的方式
5k有機會我就用我的方式
你是什麼啊
你這樣會變成四不像你知道嗎
好不好
所以你在選科度的時候
選一個
然後你就遵守那個科度告訴你的事情
剛剛的位置連15k我都不會做
因為他不是我要的東西
再來
你要做15k以前
我還是會看過60分K
所以如果我看過60K
這個的15K這個位置
我不會到很愛
因為
我不喜歡坐在
坐在一下子就撞牆的這種地方
這個不容易判斷
如果剛剛這件事情
如果剛剛的15K
它再度回來到
如果這整件事回來到
60分K的下緣
這個喔
如果在這裡
大顆度上下嘛
對不對
如果同樣的事情發生在這裡喔這個我會跳起來耶唉呦讚喔下午錯過一次如果又有類似的東西我有機會可以讓我低風險的吃
來了就吃
ok?
你說小娜現在有互換的感覺
你自此多方還空方
現在我都不太想去判斷任何多方空方
現在這邊沒有任何想法
而且,來各位
這邊你說做多支撐有道理
我剛剛為什麼說我不想要在這邊做空
因為你這邊說做空有壓力
也有道理
哇!
做多有道理,做空也有道理
我不喜歡
我只喜歡做在
只有一邊說話的地方
那這樣子我下的單子
我賠錢我心甘情願
我不會在那裡猶豫東猶豫西的
要做不做要做不做
做多空做空啊不會
我就喜欢干干净净的
这就是我的东西
这样就好
所以眼前这里
你要我做
对不起
我按不下去
而且再来
就算我现在15k要吃
我是要怎么吃
这就没有做多的标准图
标准图是长这样子
或是互换是长这样子
这就没有
我要吃什么东西
对不对
所以这个我不喜欢
好不好
就算这边喷上去
就喷啊
它前面是我不喜欢的东西
那后面它跑到哪里去
就不关我的事啊
因为前面不对了
那前面如果对了
我吃了
后面跑到哪里去
坦白讲也不关我的事
我的计划都做好了
如果到哪里我会怎么做
到哪里我要怎么凹
随便它就这样
好不好
那再来我提醒大家一下
各位
昨天的日线
是不是上面有一大堆整理区域
一大堆人做多卡在上面
对不对
然后昨天的一根日线
是直接这样翻下来
说真的
如果有回来到这边
这才是我长线很喜欢的边界
我再试着暗示大家
如果有这样子
所以各位要小心
因为一根就这样子急煞停住的几率
偶尔会出现
但是
機率偏低
我不敢說今天會不會
我只能說
長期來看這種
這種上來
然後這邊是中空
然後一根這樣彎下來
要直接擊殺
很難很難
好吧
所以各位在做的時候要小心一點
好不好
來最後
我其實還沒講完
還有一個最後一個五等
要給大家
這個五等其實是包含我們所有講的
標準圖翻亞當跟兩條線
我先在這邊畫
五等怎麼等
整理
然後兩條線以後等噴出
然後等噴出後的滿足
所以把這一段兜兜兜兜走出去
然後等下殺
然後等這一段下殺的小滿足
然後在這個地方等小刻度的標準圖
我畫太誇張了大概這樣子
所以你會在這個地方等小刻度的標準圖
这里就是完全运用了我们所有的交易
全部涵盖在一起的东西
你说老鱼这种机会很少出现
本来就很少出现
你要很常出现的
干嘛
一个真正的好机会本来就很少出现
我最近在玩那个21点
在练习算牌扑克牌
你知道那个算牌
要算到
算到那个对自己比较有利的几率偏高的时候
那个有多少
很少耶
絕大多數的時間都是在中間鬼混來鬼混去
只有非常少數
它的那個價格
它的牌面
加1-1才會是比較極度的
加7加8就已經算很多了
不然大部分都是在0啊
1啊2啊3啊
附近跑來跑去的
好不好
所以
總之
好的機會本來就少見
OK
有同學問說比特幣41500附近可以吃嗎
我都沒有看
我現在說可以吃
你敢吃嗎
要是我說不可以吃
你會不會也覺得
但是我要好想吃
你想吃就吃啊
你會問就代表你想吃你就吃啊
問我幹嘛啦
你被我念是應該的
我在念你是因為
你並沒有把你自己的交易計畫做好
你把這個重要的責任丟給我
那我就隨便亂講啦
你問我就亂講
吃啊,吃啊,對吧?
到時候停損,你又不甘願老魚叫我吃,可惡早知道就不要吃,你就不要吃啊你懂我的意思嗎?我現在在念你,但是我念的卻是很重要的東西
其實是在幫你,希望你聽得進去
你在下單之前,你需要自己去承擔
去扛起百分之百的責任
你的交易才會有所進步
不然如果你整天在網路上面問人家
可不可以,可不可以
好耶,再丟一次硬币
你整天问人家可不可以
人家也是丢硬币而已,谁会知道
你要自己去承担这件事情
这样,好不好
好,然后
所以今天五等
讲完了耶
我总觉得95%的时间
都要等待,其实还好啦
如果以我日常生活来讲
我大概50%的时间
不对
70%的时间是放在生活上
跟平常在带同学的事情上面
30%里面20%
大概25%是等待
只有5%才是真的下单的时间
这样,其他这些是生活
是逛街啊,打雨球啊,打棒球啊
这种,这样,OK
所以同学说等下沙满足超好用
超好用真的
這個五等是大絕招
如果你有真的耐心的等到這一點
那個點是賠錢都甘願
都可以按下去的點
我很愛很愛這個點
好嗎
這樣
所以眼前的圖
哇
剛剛我們不是說
剛剛這個點
這裡回來的
這個地方如果是我看盤
325這裡
剛剛這個
這個就會是好的點
你自己看哦
我们刚刚这样涂鸦
这是1K涂鸦过来
我不会拿这个就来做交易
因为我画不出他的两条线
他这个区间太小
他才两三个Tick
对不起才两三点
对吧
所以如果出现这样子
空间出来了
而那个边界
哎呀
可惜5K这边没有到很美
所以刚刚那个东西
只有一分K吃得到
15分K可能有点勉强
就你可能就要抓宽一点点
吃在这边可能都还是要锁到有啦这边10点而已15分K10點其實還OK啦26我就知道廖大說他吃26來各位
來我們來破解一下廖大
廖大吃在這裡
這根本就是我們的標準動作
尖尖的隔壁
那你看這幾根不就是
平下不去
這裡嗎對吧
就是這樣子
好不好
其實五等不需要到大顆度
就是例如說五分K
例如說這邊
上去
回來
吃
這個概念有
這個地方
我們剛剛不是有說翻亞當嗎
記得我們剛剛不是說
一秒鐘說這邊亞當差不多
對吧
所以我其實心中就有個底了
剛剛這段下殺來到這裡差不多
剛剛在這邊還說這裡不能直接吃
有沒有
你吃了會先停損一大堆
你損在這裡
這樣
好嗎
好啦
那最後跟大家溝通一個觀念
不是每一次
都一定會出現完全標準的標準圖
市場是活的
所以你真正要去理解的是
我們所定義的兩條線也好
標準圖也好
塗鴉也好
我們都是在
看市場在這個地方被怎麼對待
價格是來到這裡就長出上影線
還是來到這裡就長出下影線
那它長的位置對不對
有沒有長在比較多大人幫你撐藥的地方
這個才是我們要做的事情
所以到最後你不能說要求市場一定每一次都是
百分之百的完美演出給你看
總是會有那些
只有在1K才有的機會
5分K沒有很漂亮
15K沒有很漂亮
沒有辦法
那你說老魚像剛剛如果你用5分K你吃不到
你就吃不到啊
你就做你計劃中的K棒
計劃中的事情
那其他等級其他刻度來的
就讓別人去做
你就賺你那麼一點點你要賺的錢
其實就已經很夠用了
這樣好不好
那我們下禮拜
並沒有直播喔
下禮拜沒有直播
下禮拜大家放農曆年要休息去了
好好的跟家人過過年
那過去的經驗
農曆過年期間的美股常常會有蠻多好做的東西
這是我自己過去的經驗OK好啦那藉由我老婆拍的照片來跟大家念一下咒語好不好今天其實好像沒有講什麼
但其實所有的東西都是在
平常這些練習裡面
到最後融合到今天裡面
所以平常在我自己在做交易的時候
很多時候是
因為你看太多次了
所以你一秒鐘
兩條線翻亞當哪裡哪裡
能幹嘛大概都已經知道了
所以你问我为什么可以看得出来
很简单
我可能看了上万次
没有什么很特别的
特殊的指标
我也没有很厉害
我也是素人一个
我也喜欢穿短裤穿凉鞋
在夏天的时候都一样
好不好
来请大家跟我一起念
每天都是好棒的一天
会有好事发生在你我身上
我会尽力帮助身边的人
让他们过得更好
这个请你记得
每天早上
中午
晚上照三餐馬上唸過去就對了
有沒有要聽吉他?
我是彈古典吉他的,我其實很不會彈
而且我其實吉他已經荒廢好一段時間了
我彈一下董運昌的其中
某一首下午3點40分
我今天又在這邊換衣服又彈吉他是怎樣
诶,放大画面吼
好像是吼
放大在哪里,等我一下
诶,我等一下还有一堂课诶
还有一堂小群组的课诶
这样吗?
都在播CD是不是?
诶,我突然想到一首
我突然想到一首,我考試一下
這是很久以前某個遊戲裡面的某一段音樂
大家忘記了
优优独播剧场——YoYo Television Series Exclusive
〔此段辨識失敗，約 1:00:00 起〕